[Music]
baby kicks oh hey she wants to fight me
cardi B and offset welcome daughter
culture less than a month ago but it's
clear cardi loves bina mama
spicy bubby at some twenty five-year-old
is giving glimpses into her life as a
mom on Twitter saying it's hard to
explain how it feels but quote it's
beautiful how fast mother instinct kicks
in never want to leave my baby side
doing it for the culture and check out
this tweet quote culture is not culture
today she Kyary with the mood but oh man
I love my sweet sweet baby
Kyary his culture his middle name very
energetic to keep on going like powerful
Lake like a woman that was months before
giving birth
now cardis getting honest about how
tired she's been since becoming a mom
quote when parents say if you wake the
baby up you putting her back to sleep I
feel that my eyes are so dark and puffy
but she isn't relying on any help except
from her family just yet
I'm not guarding a nanny yet I just want
to like learn how to be a mom and I want
like to enjoy every single second of it
you know since I'm going back to work
and check out little culture's gold crib
safe to say her life is just as regal as
we'd expect all set up while I was in
the hospital and this is so gorgeous it
feels like a dream
[Applause]
you